- So in addition to
Rob's backstage popcorn,
the brothers have been working
on another exciting venture.
They're upcoming residency in Las Vegas.
(audience applauding)
I'm so excited to come see this.
Like I said I loved your show so much
when I saw you at the Bowl.
So, I am so stoked about this.
What's new?
What's gonna be happening?
- Well, there's a lot.
I mean, we haven't played a
show since October last year
and so we're obviously very excited
to get back on the stage
and this residency was actually supposed
to happen pre COVID and then COVID hit.
So this is a long time overdue for us
to bring an exciting
show to our fans in Vegas
and it's a great town for live music
and I just can't wait to
get out there and play.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God, so this was
supposed a long time ago.
Oh, man.
- Maybe some special guests, maybe Jona.
- That's exciting.
Don't invite me, mama will show up.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's how things get done there.
- I will just show up, I'm
just gonna show up singing.